question a lot of people have and when I
was watching this series I had this
question I think a lot of people would
naturally have it while you're doing the
King of Queens you're a person who's out
there in the world you're a member of
the Church of Scientology while you're
doing King of Kings and you had access
to news media you're traveling you're
going on the internet you're talking to
everybody
how were you how did you not become
aware how did you not realize sooner
that some of these things that you later
find out about the church were we're
true great question you know it would be
one thing a compound you couldn't but
but you are moving freely throughout the
world very true but you are from the
very beginning of the teachings in
Scientology you were taught that the
news is a bad place that the news lies
that's what they do that that they're
the business of life so you think try
Scientologist Christ becoming clear to
me that they go out of their way not to
promote the good works that the church
is doing and they promote that they
parishioners believe because we're told
everyday we are doing amazing things for
the world for mankind and so you're
trained and conditioned to believe that
good news will not get out there
specifically towards Scientology so the
brainwashing begins very early on and if
you do see something on the Internet
remember this organization requires that
you go in every single day two and a
half hours a day the minimum seven days
a week and so you you are conditioned to
believe that looking on the internet or
lists or watching let's say going clear
or reading something that is critical of
your church is is a transgression is a
sin and so you feel compelled to say
that the very next day that you go in
because you're going in if someone if
they're all during that time that you
were in the church if someone had said
something disparaging about the church
you had read an article you would need
to then go in to the trip to Scientology
and say I have to tell you I read this
article in Newsweek or Time magazine or
I saw this documentary and they said
these things and then you would have to
atone for it I would I would be punished
for it I would be in
tarah gated for it why am i doing that
why am i seeking out things that are
against your your church that are doing
great things for mankind where were
single-handedly saving mankind why would
you actively seek out so it's not that
information wasn't there it wasn't that
I couldn't look is that I chose not to
look because the repercussions of doing
so were great and if I said well screw
it I'm gonna look anyway and screw it
I'm gonna continue to question what
you're doing and what I'm hearing about
then they would go after your family you
know Lee is in trouble she's you know
becoming an enemy to the to organization
then they pull your family and then and
that costs thousands and thousands of
dollars so you just learn you know maybe
I just shouldn't look but you also don't
believe it not that you believe it even
right
you